boa noite
estão me ouvindo bem então vamos seguir
por aqui mesmo
quantos de vocês aqui já sentiu que foi
falar com uma outra pessoa e não foi
compreendido também quem é que já conto
algo para alguém e quando terminou
percebeu que a pessoa entendeu tudo
errado
eu também tinha que já mandou e mail uma
mensagem de texto e percebeu que não
alcançou seu objetivo
eu também
a comunicação é algo muito importante
nas nossas vidas
o que nós estamos fazendo aqui todos
inclusive neste momento é se comunicando
sim sim e se comunicando enquanto eu
falo eu vejo as cabecinhas concordando
97 por cento da nossa comunicação ela é
não verbal país então você quer me dizer
que apenas 7% do conteúdo que eu falo
pra outra pessoa realmente tem algo
impacto sim o restante
o restante são os gestos a postura a em
todas são de voz
os movimento que fazemos sorrir uma cara
às vezes de bravo quando não estamos
concordando o nosso não verbal fala
muito mais e não falar muitas vezes fala
muito mais do que falar
mais do que palavras frases ou até
textos inteiros
tudo que nós fazemos é comunicação
muitas pessoas confundem falar com se
comunicar
falar é uma das formas de se comunicar
mas ela não é não a única
quem é que sabe o que é comunicação
comunicação é quando eu gero algo uma
emoção dentro do outro
comunicação é quando eu faço algo e gera
uma sensação interna em você mesmo sem
falar
por isso a comunicação é tão importante
para o nosso conhecimento
existem formas de perceber a comunicação
que são muito claras
por exemplo imagine eu aqui falando
assim nossa gente eu tô tão feliz estou
com cara de quinta-feira eles ou alguém
assim nós eu tô numa depressão que tá
olha comunicação
toda vez que alguém se comunica com você
te causa uma sensação interna e isso sim
é comunicação
então existe algumas formas de
comunicação serem muito mais persuasivos
do que outra por exemplo você
identificar se essa pessoa é visual
auditiva ou se na estética mas qualquer
diferença
por exemplo você vai falar com uma
pessoa que é visual tome atenção dela
fala de frente pra ela e faça com que
ela olhe pra você contato visual com uma
pessoa visual é tudo
use palavras como veja
olhem claro é claro que veja que vai
fazer muito mais sentido para essa
pessoa
e uma pessoa auditiva a isso como eu
faço com ela você vai falar ela vai ser
aquela pessoa que você vai começar a
falar como eu pode falando aí que eu tô
eu tô assim não vai falando aí operando
com a audição com melhor forma de falar
com uma pessoa assim
ouça você já ouviu tal coisa passar
informação para uma pessoa auditiva não
tem tanta importância em ver os fatos
mas sim ouvir esses fatos existem também
as pessoas sinestésica que são aquelas
pessoas que normalmente aprendem fazendo
um mão na massa mesmo sabe essas pessoas
precisam sentir a informação
então o que eu vou utilizar pra falar
com essas pessoas
algo que traga a sensação para ela
ai sabe aquele cheirinho de chuva
sabe aquele gostinho de chocolate
você já sentiu a textura desse tecido
vai fazer muito mais sentido para ela
desta forma nós temos pessoas que querem
ver que são amadas que querem ouvir que
são amadas e outras que querem sentir
que são amadas
existem algumas palavras que
independente do canal preferencial dessa
pessoa em causa uma limitação ou causa
uma ação que palavras são essas
hoje eu vou dar três palavrinhas dessas
pra vocês
a primeira é ou não não normalmente é
pra você para o não têm representação
aqui dentro que diz assim não seguido
preste atenção no restante da frase
vamos fazer um teste rápido não pense
agora não pense num elefante rosa com
bolinhas brancas não pensa num elefante
rosa com bolinhas brancas não eu falei
que era pra não pensar num elefante rosa
como lembra a palavra que vem seguido
não ela vai te estar em evidência
então não é não uma palavra muito eficaz
para se iniciar uma frase por exemplo
outra palavra que é bem interessante
ainda falando não o fato é este com uma
criança por exemplo fala que a criança
se não joga e quem não joga
ela olha você o novo ela deletou o joga
concluído com sucesso
nós temos essa experiência também com
outra palavra chamada difícil
isso aqui é tão difícil
eu tô aqui olha com isso aqui é muito
difícil essa receita é muito difícil só
que é muito difícil extremamente
limitante palavra que te para este
limita e diz pra você você não vai
perceber aí você troca o difícil e
coloca o desafiador o ser humano adora
ser desafiado fala para ele que é um
desafio que eu quero ver se ele vai
querer resolver
olha eu toco um desafio que é aqui que é
que a gente vai resolver
palavra de ação tal uma sensação interna
de você querer realizar algo
isso é muito importante para o ser
humano ea terceira palavrinha é a
palavra problema
quem nunca gente problema e palavra mais
pesada você fez valer essa falando eu tô
com um problema pessoal de alguns já
imaginou você recebe uma ligação à noite
assim desce aqui que eu tô com o
problema
frio na hora né porque você não sabe que
é como trocar o problema por uma outra
palavra que causa uma ação incrível e
qual é essa palavra oi
o desafio desafiante questão em vez de
falar olha eu estou com um problema você
vai dizer que é uma questão porque é uma
questão porque é uma questão ela é
resolvível desde quando a gente é
pequenininho
a gente recebe que questões abertas
fechadas para serem preenchidas e
resolvidas
então a questão a deixa comigo resolver
as coisas é comigo mesmo gera uma ação e
não mais uma limitação é muito
importante essas escolhas no nosso dia a
dia
falando de comunicação
qual tem sido a ferramenta mais
utilizada de comunicação no mundo hoje
isso mesmo o smartphone
o celular tem sido a ferramenta mais
utilizada no mundo hoje que lá nós
mandamos e-mails
falamos por aplicativos compramos
passagem aérea hotel talvez até alguns
de vocês tenham feito a inscrição no ted
pelo smartphone muito bem e aí a
quantidade de informação e comunicação
diária é enorme em 9 visual auditiva
nós temos toneladas de informação e essa
informação nem sempre é de qualidade
muitas vezes essa informação e rasa
quando os aplicativos hoje que nós
utilizamos que tem 15 segundos pra você
capta essa informação o minuto da
capital essa informação
então a vida em até um minuto porque eu
tenho um minuto para ver isso aqui
depois ele vai começar de novo é vida
era próximo próximo vídeo 15 segundos
passa próximo vídeo próxima pessoa
próxima e venta ea grande quantidade de
informação chegando e não sendo
concluída
é como se mentalmente nós tivéssemos uma
tela do monitor e ela tivesse cheia de
abas abertas quando nós temos um
computador com 30 40 50 telas abertas a
memória fica bobo fica ruim
o computador fica rápido ou fica lento e
aí nós temos que ir lá e fechando essas
abelhas sem e mentalmente é isso que tem
acontecido
o professor augusto cury tem usado uma
sigla chamado da síndrome do pensamento
acelerado
isso tem acontecido só com jovens tão
recentemente fui dar uma palestra para
crianças pra pais de crianças de quatro
meses a 65 anos de idade
eu fui falar com inteligência emocional
se aprende brincando você acredita que
esses mesmos sintomas dos jovens
a gente tem visto em criança de dois
anos
como você vai se comunicar com alguém
está com a cabeça completamente cheia ea
dificuldade de dormir de armazenar novas
informações e o que acontece com a nossa
memória começa a ficar meio ruim
uma pergunta que eu quero deixar aqui
pra vocês hoje
isso que eu falei pra vocês hoje é um
dos pressupostos da pnl que é impossível
o indivíduo não se comunicar nós estamos
nos comunicando dn formas eu dei vários
exemplos aqui pra vocês hoje ea pergunta
que deixo para vocês é o seguinte nós
estamos escolhendo a melhor forma de se
comunicar
hoje será que é a melhor forma que a
gente escolher dois sente muito obrigado
[Aplausos]